welcome back to cbs mornings just two
months ago more than 120 000 people were
evacuated from afghanistan in what was
one of the largest humanitarian airlifts
in history but in the chaos that ended
america's longest war countless afghans
who helped american troops were left
behind some are now living in fear that
the taliban will find them and kill them
mts tayab is in afghanistan forest where
he spoke with two of those refugees
america's longest war could not have
been fought without afghan allies from
translating to gathering intelligence
tens of thousands assisted in the fight
working with u.s forces through thick
and thin
like khan not his real name a former
interpreter with the military he's now
jobless and living in hiding with his
young family after receiving what he
says are repeated death threats from the
taliban how long are you going to be
able to survive living like this without
a job
i don't know
honestly i request from the united
states president biden
that
you're told
you will never
behind
all those
who worked with the united states
government please shelter us we don't
want to our our kids become orphans
are you angry at the us
honestly yes
this is me
uh at the u.s embassy in kabul and
that's you with the american ambassador
yeah
not his real name either says he's a
wanted man a former u.s embassy employee
he spent nearly a year working in
intelligence screening other afghan
staff for potential links to militancy
why are you so afraid of the taliban
they announced those people who work
with foreign
they are not muslim
they are the same as american they we
should kill them
in the military's chaotic final days in
afghanistan soldiers were tasked to help
afghans who qualified for special
immigrant visas or sivs
but it became a
free-for-all and tamim who was in the
crush of people desperate to get out
could not as hard as he tried we went to
deer for two weeks
sleeping there were they are during the
night and
you slept outside the airport yeah
exactly because there was no other way
since leading the evacuation of nearly
125 000 people from afghanistan
following the taliban takeover in august
the largest evacuation in u.s history
the biden administration has faced
mounting criticism over leaving behind
hundreds of americans as well as tens of
thousands of afghans who supported the
u.s mission
the taliban insists its fighters won't
harm anyone who once worked for the
united states as part of what it's
calling a general amnesty
it's not true no one believed oliver
because you don't believe them i don't
believe them
for cbs mornings i'm inf
bringing us the reality of what's
happening there thank you so much